[Music]
on this Friday night the mission to
solve the murders of three indigenous
women in Manitoba an indigenous-led
committee's recommendations about
searching this landfill you cannot put a
price on the lives of First Nation women
an Alberta man's heartbreaking loss this
is a little overwhelming he went from
moving into his new home to homeless
legalizing discrimination to be
targeting trans kids was angering and
saddening how Tennessee is targeting
transgender people
and WestJet pilots on a flight path to a
potential strike the advice for
customers
global national we Ed with Bara Nasser
we're getting a clearer picture tonight
what it could take to search a Winnipeg
landfill for three missing indigenous
women
police believe Morgan Harris Mercedes
Myron and an unidentified woman were
murdered and their remains are buried
somewhere in the prairie green landfill
a study examining the feasibility of the
investigation founder could take years
and cost up to 184 million dollars but
the report warns not conducting the
search could cause considerable distress
if a search is not carried out
it will demonstrate to all First Nations
across Canada
that this government condones
the despairing Act of disposing our
first nation women in landfills
it breaks my heart to say these words
disposing of our women in landfills
the report was commissioned by an
indigenous-led committee after police
said they would not search for the
victim's remains Melissa Ridge has our
top story tonight
but at the end of the day no matter what
it takes or what it's going to cost we
are going to do that work we are going
to look for our loved ones a feasibility
study concludes that murder victims
Morgan Harris Mercedes Myron and the
third unidentified woman called buffalo
woman deserve the Dignity of a search
and their family's closure it could take
12 to 36 months for Crews to sort
through tens of thousands of tons of
densely compacted waste at the Prairie
green landfill including animal bones
and asbestos you cannot put a price on
the lives of First Nation woman or the
horrific and profound loss their
families have experienced they say not
searching would signal to this country
that the national inquiry into missing
and murdered indigenous women and girls
was performative and that the
disproportionate rate of indigenous
women being murdered in this country
doesn't matter this feasibility study is
55 pages long and as
on paper can give you enough reasons as
to why you should search for a woman
because it should have been done on the
first page the feasibility study made
recommendations Beyond just calling for
a search to make indigenous women less
vulnerable including increased funding
for social supports and programming for
First Nations and Indigenous peoples an
indigenous homeless shelters also they
want mandatory GPS tracking for all
waste removal trucks in Canada and
rear-facing cameras on those Vehicles as
well as video surveillance at landfill
entrances and exits to implement the
recommendations there's a call for more
funding for smaller communities while
they say without support from the
federal provincial and Municipal
governments a search would happen anyway
prime minister Justin Trudeau seems to
be on board as we've said from the very
beginning the federal government will be
there to support in this grieving and
healing process we know how atrocious
and how difficult this is for the
families and we will do whatever we can
to help Melissa Ridge in Global News
long plane First Nation Manitoba
an intense early season Heat Wave across
much of western Canada is expected to
break records this weekend and fuel the
wildfires that are already burning
across Alberta Environment Canada has
issued a special weather statement for
most of BC and Alberta it warns maximum
highs will be close to 30 degrees 10 to
15 degrees above seasonal Norms those
hot dry conditions are Fanning the
Flames of dozens of wildfires in Alberta
and this is newly released satellite
photos that shows what it looks like
from space more than 400 000 hectares
have already burned more than double the
area burned in all of last year smoke
from the virus has stretched out across
the entire country as Heather York's
West reports people are assessing their
losses as the province braces for what's
ahead
the decimated Resort community of
lobstic Alberta there is an eerie calm
fire has done its worst here leaving
behind only the charred remains of homes
the idea it was just Paradise there was
nothing it didn't have Conrad scar root
lives here only two days before fire
tore through his beautiful new house
ashes now and yeah this is a little
overwhelming so I'm trying to take it in
and just trying to keep my composure at
the moment scar root says he'd like to
rebuild but those kinds of plans will
have to wait with more dangerous weather
ahead temperatures up to 28 degrees
Celsius low humidity levels of 17 to 15
percent
winds 20 to 25 from the southeast
gusting up to 40 and 45 into Sunday
those are very challenging weather
conditions is definitely going to put
our firefighters and our control lines
to the test
it's been a week since the Bush Creek
Wildfire forced the evacuation of
Drayton Valley but with temperatures
Rising officials say the more than 7 000
residents won't be returning to the
community anytime soon plus 28 for the
weekend so that's all pray and hope we
get some
a mother nature helps us out because
it's not just the fire that poses a
threat on Friday morning 14 people were
injured in a highway traffic pileup
caused by the heavy smoke it looked like
a war zone there were vehicles in the
ditch all over the road there's pieces
of vehicles all over the place 300
Canadian Armed Forces members are now on
the ground in Alberta to assist with a
fire fight fighting once again not a
foreign threat but the impact of our
changing climate Heather your ex West
Global News
in the U.S immigration Advocates wasted
little time following a lawsuit against
the Biden administration's new policy of
limiting Asylum for those who cross the
southern border without authorization an
estimated 60 thousand migrants were
waiting near the U.S Mexico border as
the pandemic border policy known as
title 42 ended last night the American
civil liberties Union among others have
called the strict new Asylum rules cruel
and illegal in a lawsuit filed less than
an hour after title 42 officially
expired they say the new regulations
mere restrictions from the Trump era
that were previously blocked by the
courts
a wave of anti-transgender laws is
sweeping across the U.S with a growing
number of states passing bans on gender
affirming care for minors some of the
most restrictive measures will come into
effect in Tennessee a state that's also
targeting transition care for adults as
Jackson prosco reports families with
transgender children now face greater
risk and uncertainty while wondering if
they'll be forced to move
did you ever reach a point where you
thought to yourself can we support our
child and stay in Tennessee absolutely
um I think we've wondered that all along
the way
Asheville Mother's identity to protect
her and her young transgender daughter
she seems very comfortable in who she is
for speaking to us she risks harassment
for supporting her child she could one
day run a foul of Tennessee law I am
fearful of you know being targeted my
kids being targeted being determined
like an
incompetent or coercive parent the
five-year-old has socially transitioned
as she gets older she may one day choose
to begin hormone therapies she likely
won't be able to do it in Tennessee the
state leads the U.S in anti-transgender
laws for literally the first bill of the
entire session to be targeting trans
kids was angering and saddening in March
Tennessee Republicans passed a ban on
gender affirming medical care for minors
the law known as sb1 also forces teens
who are already undergoing treatment to
stop and detransition we needed to have
more data on this and in the meantime I
thought we needed to put a halt to it an
adult can decide what treatment they
want they don't care about folks waiting
until 18 they just want to ban the care
period Darren Johnson is a transgender
woman and Community Advocate she worries
the state will soon move to out law
transgender care for adults too we would
be creating situations that Force our
own citizens to be refugees within our
own countries the circle of places the
list of places that folks can go is
getting smaller and smaller just to be
able to live our lives what happens next
will be decided by the courts the U.S
justice department has sued Tennessee
arguing its laws are both discriminatory
and unconstitutional without
intervention by a judge Tennessee's ban
on transgender care for minors will come
into effect July 1st so at what point do
you have to make some tough decisions
about whether you can stay here our
whole approach
to all of this is really like to let her
lead we don't want to box her in and say
like you know this is definitely what's
going to happen when she's a teenager
and definitely how she's going to be as
an adult facing so much uncertainty the
parents of transgender children have no
choice but to plan for every possible
outcome even if it means leaving the
place they call home
Jackson prosco Global News Nashville
after nearly seven chaotic months of
leadership Twitter has a new CEO honor
Elon Musk has hired former NBC Universal
ad executive Linda yaccarino he says she
will focus on business operations
including digging the company out of
heavy debt musk says he will transition
to product software and system
operations musk became CEO in October
after his 44 billion dollar purchase of
the social media giant the Hostile
takeover LED advertisers to flee along
with billions of dollars in Revenue in
December musk said he'd step aside once
he'd found someone foolish enough to
take the job yaccarino starts in six
weeks
a crash course to criminal charges
[Music]
coming up the potential punishment for a
pilot's social media stunt
[Music]
YouTuber Trevor Daniel Jacob is pleaded
guilty to U.S federal charges for this
2021 video where he ditched a plane and
let it crash on purpose to gain views
online the 29 year old admitted to one
count of Destruction and concealments to
obstruct a federal investigation a plea
agreement says he lied to investigators
by claiming the crash was accidental
then destroyed the plane's wreckage he
could face up to 20 years in prison
it it's been a turbulent time for air
travel with countless flight
cancellations and lengthy delays and if
you're planning on jumping on a plane in
the next few weeks prepare for even more
disruptions WestJet Pilots are getting
ready to strike as early as Tuesday the
union representing them says the airline
has a sky-high turnover rate and Pilots
are overworked and underpaid tonight Ann
gaviola looks at what it could mean for
your long weekend plans
WestJet Pilots are already picketing
airports on their days off but they're
poised to walk off the job May 16th just
in time to complicate travel plans for
the long weekend the union representing
1700 pilots flying for WestJet and swoop
says the two sides are far apart on job
security working conditions and pay
we're currently paid about 45 percent of
what the North American average is that
Gap has to narrow WestJet is owned by
private Equity Firm Onyx and says Pilots
are fairly compensated among their
Canadian peers raising an expectation
that you can live in one country and
then Cherry Pig wages from another one
is just not how the world works but
Global competition for Pilots is heating
up because of a shortage that's worsened
since 2020. passengers on canceled
flights can expect notifications you
will be getting an email an SMS a text
maybe even a phone call if you're really
lucky
um that will advise you that your flight
has been canceled and here are your
options travel expert Leslie cater says
people who need to fly to make it to a
cruise or a tour package should consider
buying a more expensive fully refundable
ticket on a rival carrier as backup and
all passengers are advised to find out
what is and isn't covered under
insurance if you have an insurance
policy that has a council for any reason
component then that might be useful for
you but bear in mind for something like
this you would probably have to cancel
within five days or so of departure and
you won't get a full refund could be
anything from 50 to 80 percent there
will be a bump in terms of demand for
passengers as a result of westjet's
cancellations
um I believe there's enough capacity in
the marketplace today with all of these
new carriers that will be in a situation
that those passengers will be
accommodated in very short order
passengers in northern BC Northern
Alberta and the Prairie Provinces where
WestJet is the predom carrier may find
themselves with few alternatives
and gaviola Global News Toronto
turkey's uncertain future ahead the
questions and controversy swirling
around a political giant fighting to
stay in power
[Music]
Ukrainian military commanders say their
troops have regained ground in the
Eastern Battlefield city of buckmut
aware Advance after months of fierce
fighting
[Music]
you princess they've taken back about
two kilometers from the Russians this
week and reopened a critical Supply
Route Russia admits its soldiers have
fallen back to Old defensive positions
it's unclear if this is the official
start of Ukraine's much anticipated
counter-offensive but it is a major
shift in momentum Russia has been trying
to take over the Strategic City for 11
months
voters in Turkey head to the polls on
Sunday for a closely watched and
possibly historic election President
erdogan is looking for another five
years in office adding to his already
decades long stint in power but
erdogan's facing his toughest
presidential challenge yet as the
country struggles with a crippled
economy and tries to recover from the
largest natural disaster in its modern
history Crystal commencing Reports
he's moved turkey from a parliamentary
system to an executive presidency he
survived a military coup and is the
longest serving leader in the history of
the Turkish Republic
calling the opposition Coalition
pro-lgbtq and accusing it of siding with
terrorists reject erdogan is trying to
Rally his base in hopes of securing a
third term as president
for two decades erdogan has labeled
himself a defender of democracy while
consolidating power just before Sunday's
general election claims Russia has
interfered in favor of erdogan
we find it unacceptable for another
country to interfere in turkey's
domestic affairs
this fake video has been circulating
showing the opposition leader saying
come on together to The Ballot Box
turkey come on but it was edited to
include pkk leaders a militant group
designated a terrorist organization by
both turkey and Canada
in the polls Camille College Derulo has
a slight Edge over erdogan he shared the
original videos on his Twitter page and
says he is concrete proof against Russia
Russia denies the allegations what can't
be denied is the ongoing grief three
months after deadly earthquake struck
the Red Cross says in Turkey
2.7 million people are living in tents
many blame erdogan for shoddy building
construction and a slow emergency
response more than 45 thousand people
died following the disaster
mismanagement cronyism and inflation
could spell the end of erdogan but he
has made a career out of turning the
tide
Crystal demands in Global News London
residents of a Swiss Village have been
ordered out over concerns a nearby
Mountainside May collapse
geologists predict a major slide could
happen as early as next week the village
could be buried in up to 2 million cubic
meters of rock officials say they
considered a controlled explosion and a
wall to mitigate the disaster but those
options aren't feasible people have been
told to pack up and leave by tonight
scientists say higher temperatures
triggered by climate change have led to
an increase in erosion
[Music]
momentum building next the calls to
strengthen Canadian building codes to
protect against destructive tornadoes
this might come as a surprise Canada has
the second highest number of recorded
tornadoes in the world we're just behind
the U.S a lot of the time Twisters
touched down in remote areas but when
they hit residential areas the damage
well it can be catastrophic experts say
Canada's building codes need to be
revamped to keep up with our new climate
reality as Candace Daniel reports
there's a simple and affordable Solution
that's been around for years
it all happened so fast it was totally
like a bomb went off I mean it was
devastating this is what was left of Rob
garrard's Brewery after a violent
tornado hit Uxbridge Ontario
our roof was literally picked up and
flown across the street that tornado was
part of a derecho the storm traveled
from Ontario into Quebec on the May long
weekend of 2022.
Gregory comp has spent decades trying to
make homes more resilient to windstorms
we have to understand how buildings
perform in them but while we're doing
that we can also understand how to
design better part of his work is to
figure out how many tornadoes Canada
gets
using radar and satellite imagery they
discovered Canada ranks number two
worldwide for the most tornadoes
Canada's second in the world why do we
care about this as a population grows
and we spread out and what is the true
level of risk understanding the risk
level is important as the effects of
climate change worsen
so far updates to Canadian building
codes to tackle global warming have
mostly been focused on Energy Efficiency
measures to tackle the potential
increase in extreme winds are still
being assessed often in these events the
the whole roof comes off and you're just
left there with walls so the top of the
wall are these two by fours Gregory says
one solution to strengthen the roof
could be to install hurricane straps the
small steel bracket helps to secure the
connection between the roof to the wall
making the roof more resilient to
aggressive winds some Builders use them
others don't they are not mandatory this
technology has been around for a long
time we know it works it's just not
common here the Canadian homebuilders
Association told Global News hurricane
straps alone are not a silver bullet the
whole house needs to be considered and
assessed I think we should be putting
this in the code and we should be
thinking about resilience measures in
general as for Rob Garrard in Oxbridge
he plans to reopen his Brewery next
weekend on the one-year anniversary of
the tornado he decided to rebuild and
this time the construction included
hurricane straps pharah
Kenneth Daniel in Toronto thanks for
that Candace and to learn more about how
Canada's building codes stock up against
extreme weather watch Candace's full
story on the new reality Saturday at 7
pm right here on global and that's
global national for this Friday night
I'm Farah Nasser on behalf of our whole
crew here I want to thank you so much
for spending part of your evening with
us tonight's your Canada is Ashcroft
British Columbia until tomorrow take
care of yourselves and take care of each
other good night
thank you
foreign